[Music]
foreign
okay you're
Bert and I on podcasts we are such good
friends you guys but I also want you to
know where is such Savvy business people
we will be uh murder your thirst yeah we
will be like secretly 700 million buddy
and we will be keep it growing we will
be that's the first time Birds ever
drink water the only reason I drink the
only water are we rolling yeah
this is how uh hard it is to get me to
drink water I only drink water because I
invested in liquid Dash I invested into
I will tell you this right now I fucking
the only reason I drink water is liquid
death I swear to God because of the
delivery system do you know about the
new iced tea all right heard about the
armors Palmer dude it's
for real
[Music]
toxic I'm not being Ellen I fucking love
this woman all right guys I have a
special call Razzle Dazzle streaming
right now on Netflix you can catch it
it's my fifth special I have a movie
called The Machine it comes out Memorial
Day Weekend only in theaters you can
pre-buy tickets at themachine.movie and
we are having a special event Thursday
night in the theaters themselves it will
be a live streamed event onto the screen
it's going to be fucking big it's going
to be epic I can't really go into too
much detail about it but most
importantly my tour fully loaded just
went on General on sale today I've got
an insane lineup on fully loaded
Whitney's doing my cruise the fully
loaded Cruise that's already sold out
but I'm bringing some of my family
members to that it's gonna be a fucking
ride it's going to be it's it should be
just fun everything I want to do is just
fun I can Bert I love you so much I love
you more I'm just that could be true
because I don't know what love is I say
it I also say it knowing I don't think
I'm clear on the definition
um but I do like
you like I'm so like I'm learning how
feral I am I feel like you've got all
comedians do this before I do a really
good phrase feral yeah I like didn't
have love in my uh I used to call Leanna
rescue dog
because she was she was a pit bull and
she would bite and snap and and um
yeah and so I used to have to teach her
how to fight because she wanted to to
growl and bark and and bite and she
wanted to bite yeah and I had to say and
you get your dick out of can I have my
dick out of your mouth before you bite
please oh my gosh he sneezed one time no
I'm kidding so um but she and so then we
we
I and still she's not great at it you
can definitely see the time that she was
chained to a a railroad fence and the
truck would go by fast and she still
sometimes has a hard time apologizing
and by sometimes I mean all the times
but she can get there she can get there
it just takes a night of sleep to wake
up and go I'm sorry but for all the
stuff so I called her I've done by the
way this could be an entire bit I called
her a rescue dog because she was of her
energy and she said well you're a penny
stock I don't think anyone was going to
invest in you except for me and I'm a
fucking billionaire because I I saw the
value in a penny stock that's genius I
also would say like like when people say
to me like and that's always how I try
to explain myself to people I'm like an
abused dog that when I growl I love that
you say you're feral though I was never
parented I was never socialized but
you're a beautiful cat that is feral
that is that's such a great thing
because you raised yourself you fixed
yourself but can I say something really
quick
defense because Leanne and I are the
same person uh insult to her compliment
to me
um where the same person except I would
rather put a bullet in my brain than
have sex with you uh
it's not that it's not bad it's over
before you know it it's like getting
your ears pierced you feel a little
prick and it's over
cheers
in that case you can fuck my ear I'd
sooner have you fuck the ear on the side
of my head that was actually bitch
me on
like
I could be sexy around you and it's just
like funny oh yeah like oh the best the
best is you gave my assistant Pete a hug
and I know I know what Pete thinks about
you and I watched his him get genuinely
fucking nervous he's like oh oh oh it's
with me it's with me I fully know
because right now I understand how
annoying it must be to have to hear a
woman speak that you have no that you're
not gonna fuck at any point I'm
realizing more and more so when I start
like as a boss my new leadership style
is when I am explaining something that
needs to happen to men and their eyes
start glazing over I just pull my shirt
up it works I think it's illegal I think
wait do you because I've seen I've seen
that bra a lot do you have do you have
like sexy bras
um that's a sexy bra but it's right back
because hold on
I would love to see this as would all of
you viewing back to my point my my fully
loaded tour is insane it's gonna be a
blast I I the list of people I could
read them off but I can bring in my
memory Jim Norton uh Lewis Black David
tell uh Jane Gillis come on in Shane
Shane Gillis is one of the top five
hangs in the world can I tell you
something just so you know because I
wanted to tell you a little bit about
the roast the behind the scenes stuff
that you didn't know about I tried to
get Shane Gillis we couldn't get it
going yeah you know Joey Diaz yeah Joey
Diaz yeah you know and do you know about
the what happened with David tell he was
just on the podcast two days ago no I
just yeah I was just out here no what
happened tell like so for Bert's roast
and only fans we have Clips to play that
are cut if we want to if we get to it we
get to it I also want to run the
guestlist by you for the premiere please
I have to like narrow this down yeah
we're gonna do a lot of admin on this
podcast
um and uh uh so it tell his you know
he's I don't want to get too into his
personal he's a family member that is in
you know home care and kovid was kind of
research we got to the point where we
were gonna get Fly Dave private because
he didn't want to contract covid because
his uh mother is in a you know
um compromising Health situation also
just to be clear during your roast while
we were shooting it my mom was in home
hospice dying yeah it was the most
surreal like I didn't want to tell
anyone I didn't want to involve anyone
but I was coming back and forth from I
knew that I knew that you know what I
mean so so it was just this wild thing
and I think for me it just it it the
whole experience made me re fall in love
with comedy and like what we do because
I was like I'm watching my mom slowly
die in front of me and I don't want to
get too into it because I don't want
anyone to pity me but this is a woman
that just didn't I didn't get love it's
fine yeah uh she made me funny she made
whatever I am I have to thank her for
the University I mean she had like when
you're in home hospice like you're not
supposed to use energy so you're only
allowed to because the idea is that
they're dying naturally but if you go
and talk to them too much or excite that
they're going to use more energy and
you're gonna they're gonna die faster so
the idea is that they died naturally
slowly and they're dying of dehydration
you're watching someone like die of
dehydration in front of you so that's
why you can't give anyone at home
hospice food
because
that's why I keep showing my um my
literally Annie Letterman says where do
you get your bras the Holocaust Museum
I do wear bras that look like Band-Aids
I don't know what else to tell you but
I'm going to show you the sexy bras in a
second oh perfect um brought to you so
sweet by Bluetooth and what how much
does it cost a day well that's a good
that's a good plug
um what how much does the hospice cost
today
um I don't I didn't check because if I
guess it's not something you want to see
him on well I mean here's what here's
what I hear you're just saying if it's a
thousand bucks a day I might scare him a
couple times just to fucking wrap it up
so when Kaiser Permanente
um I will see you guys in court
um uh the food court I'm not suing
anyone I don't have time I'm not gonna
park on the basketball court it's a dunk
contest and we're bringing Tom's girl
because he's gonna need you later
by the way people like like I have been
so um wronged by so in so many
situations like you know you could sue
that person right I'm like
imagine me adding to my plate
if I sued everyone who took advantage of
me and still for me it's all I would do
I know
I know a guy God I want to tell you off
the camera but hold on hold on real
quick okay oh so Kaiser permission we
can't tell you a secret for the past I
know a guy who told me never to sue who
sued you
laughs
oh here's my deal
um I I uh and and I can't oh I shouldn't
say this publicly but whatever I'll I'll
fight some things other things I'll
settle yeah because like the first time
someone ever sued me it was after I I
was on a billboard for the NBC shows I
was Billboards everywhere my business
manager told me it's like very common
when someone first starts you know
getting something starts getting money
small claims court
uh lawsuits will start coming in and
they know you're busy they know you're
on a billboard they know you newly have
money and that you're just gonna not
either not show up in small claims court
if you don't show up usually the person
that did show up will win or all claims
court you know small claims court yeah
touch Duty it's it's it's it's
um my hero uh Byron Allen one of my
business mentors goes you know where the
real money is in TV
Court shows and religion
really that's crazy we're also trying to
be as popular as Joel Olsteen I have a
court religion show really yeah well
you're being Sinners up in front of me
tell you your sins and then and then you
always forgive them at the end
I want to make I want to make TV shows
again Whitney
I think I'm back by the way I have a
very specific I have what is it I have a
very specific set of skills what does
Liam Neeson say in the taken oops I peed
my pants well there's that have you seen
the photos of um oh no I know what Liam
Neeson said but you know he was gonna
just beat up any black
mask did you did you see did you ever
see that clip why would he share that
it's such a crazy thing to share I
understand racism uh that was but you
know how his wife died right she hit her
fucking head on the bunny slope dude I
didn't realize you know because I'm
obsessed with how the Richer you get
the more dangerous uh your life gets
which is why I freak out but sometimes
with the like flying chart or all this
kind of stuff like I think you know rich
people like you're safer and you're
safer and you're safer and then your kid
skis into a tree and dies like what like
you know people that have a lot of money
they don't die from like you know cancer
this that because they have medical care
but why are you uh sliding down a piece
of ice on an ice skate in in Switzerland
this is how they die that's what I'm
afraid oh yeah Natasha Richardson Liam
Neeson's wife yeah goes on the skis I
think skiing is psychotic I love this
song I don't get it I love it so much I
grew up but how did you learn skiing if
you grew up in Florida I didn't wow
that's so interesting no we all
wakeboarded and water skied and there is
a similarity it's very easy to kind of
translate the two the two crafts and so
we would go up to North Carolina to
Beach Mountain and Ski Beach and
Snowboard up there we were the first
Generations we were snowboarding before
they had snowboard boots when you just
had to wear like shoes you know that I
shattered my shoulder snowboarding for
real is that was it a date it was to
impress uh Pete Berg the director I was
dating uh my boyfriend at the time he
was great at snowboarding so was his son
I was like I need to learn to snowboard
and here's the problem with me I am I'm
like you I'm actually low-key secretly
yeah you're not even low-key athletic
you're very athletic and I can kind of
figure anything out if it's not a new
skit so I was like I was doing I took
lessons and I was like okay I'm gonna be
able to do this this is Whitney Cummings
101. I've never done this before in two
days I'm gonna be the best at it yep
and involve everyone and then have a a
public meltdown uh a manic breakdown
there's nothing worse than when a woman
gets hurt
um okay uh do you want me to look at the
PornHub top videos today why is that
what they are I don't think people agree
with you
I don't understand rough sex and this is
why I love you uh so much Bert because
you are and this is why you're the only
man I could roast
because you think that way
um but we're jumping around because I
also have you not seen Liam Neeson when
he's taking pictures with fans no
about this I'm getting up Pat Don't
Panic or yell at me he pisses his pants
no that's not real it's real no you
didn't know about this whenever you take
a picture with him he pisses his pants
no he's in the publicly
it's like for years
it's about it it's the
why can men just piss their pants
publicly
hold on so Liam Neeson
and he said what is it uh p
ee that's fucking crazy wait why does he
yeah yeah I'm looking at all of this why
is he is that not photoshopped in why
every single one no type in Burke
Chrysler pieces pants
pee in your pants is cool then leave
Nathan's cool
play the gender card
IO um
have one manic episode
I'm forever crazy but Liam Neeson gets
to piss his pants yeah that is fucking
crazy there's no you will go you cannot
find me wetting my pants anywhere on the
internet I piss my pants
for men sometimes it's like you go to
the bathroom and then you put your dick
back in your pants and then it releases
a flood of piss no no no I know what
that is because I remember at a young
age seeing my dad I I always got
confused he'd go to the bathroom and
come back and there would be like a
little wet spot yeah does that mean
you're not wearing underwear you didn't
shake your day well it mostly means
you're not wearing underwear I don't
wear underwear and so uh why but what
what is what's the logic on that just
serious
I I think it's for me it's a tactile
thing the idea to be wearing two sets of
pants would drive me fucking do you
think that's a Florida thing because it
was stupid thing I mean I
I learned it from the boys older than me
and so I and the first step was box so
what was really cool when I was a kid is
to wear boxers longer than your pants to
have your boxer sticking out the bottom
of your pants that was a fucking look
that was a cool look you know what else
was I I'm gonna co-sign with do you
remember MTV's The Grind yeah this is
how dumb we are as a species
I thought it was the coolest thing on
the fucking planet when I was living in
Roanoke Virginia
uh I'd watch MTV's The Grind and the
what the girls would do they'd have jean
shorts they'd unzip their pants like
this and they'd love this
and we'd show our underwear and it was
just they would dance like this Jesus
Christ how much do you weigh you are
skinny I know I've um those are my hip
bones I am uh uh I went off birth
control first of all good for you good
for you for 20 years I've been on birth
control good for you it's earth goes a
fucking I'm gonna be I'm gonna take a
stand side it wouldn't normally take for
the past 50 years
birth control is a fucking racket it's
so much more than that and it's and it's
and it's hormones in your body that
could cause Strokes could cause blood
clotting it's it's unnatural and in a
weird way Society kind of signed up and
said oh yeah the chicks will take care
of that you guys get combed in and you
got to take care of the cum it's like
it's it's almost like a guy that why
wouldn't they just make men's birth
control
yeah there's that uh we've tried to do
it you know we're like come on my face
come on my tits oh is that oh my God
that's precious that's women's attempt
to get off birth controls letting us
come just come in my eyes
I'm we're just trying to get not be on
birth control come on my tits come on my
ass come my armpit come on my any oh my
God that is so anything but my pussy
that is the funniest fucking angle then
why aren't you laughing no but I'm I'm
Blue
[Music]
female comedian you say this
is the funniest thing I've ever heard
laughing why do I do is for a living
women aren't funny even when we say
funny things
I never realized I think I'm just
realizing uh my that I I was I was so
close to the trees I couldn't see the
actual forest and I go so you're telling
me yes the the I had a joke about this
girl that I dated and she wanted me to
come on her face and I was like she goes
do you want to come on my face that's
her saying I don't want to have your kid
yeah I'd rather it's a way to get
control over it like like uh almost like
like when when the kidnappers are like
um like it's almost like you're dealing
with kidnappers and you've got to be
like
hey man uh take me and let the kids go
you know like it's it's a way to like
that's fucking fascinating yeah that
word not saying I want your cum in my
eye so that I have a weird twitch for
the rest of the week at work we're
saying I ca I can't stress out for the
next three months thinking I'm pregnant
I can't afford a birth control I don't
want to be on birth control I just I
couldn't oh my god dude
we make we make pussies out of our tits
do it here you got pizza tension
wait it's a it's a it's a Kung Fu move
what is it Taekwondo when you use
someone's energy against them that's so
fucking brilliant
is it I mean we're obviously not good
enough at it because you guys I never
realized it but this is the cruel joke
of biology is that it feels the best
without a condom inside no
well that's maybe just for you no I you
know I
I think I fucked that up somehow like
for some reason my favorite orgasm is
the one I'm trying to stop
I'm dating a guy right now who's uh what
is it called a uh um edging oh
tell me about this
well is he just punching a wall right
now I want to tell you something about
what's going on with who I'm dating the
story is so good Bert really I told Ari
about it he went I I will bring back
this is not happening just for you to
tell this story that's how good this
what's going on with the guy I'm dating
is but we'll get to that another time
look and feel your best in time for
warmer weather with calorie smart meals
around 550 calories or less if you're
too busy to cook or don't want to cook
use Factor meals you skip the trip to
the grocery store skip the chopping the
prepping and the cleaning helps me eat
healthy when I'm having a busy week I
love their options they sent me meals
after my mom had passed away and it's
the only meals I got
that made my life easier and not harder
if that's not the best endorsement for
this company I don't know what is head
to factormeals.com whitney50 and use
code whitney50 to get 50 off your first
box that's code whitney50 at
factormeels.com whitney50 to get 50 off
your first box
I'm having a little bit of a bird came
in today you guys and I just like
grabbed him by the hands I don't think I
wasn't hugged as a child I wasn't
touched a lot you know I'm weird about
physical I was touched but just by like
The Hitchhikers my dad took in who
molested me so I
I wasn't touched the right ways only the
wrong ways and I grabbed her by the hand
this is the most intimacy I've ever had
with a man was earlier in my home 40
years old I just had this weird thing
where I publicly like been this certain
person because I was under the influence
of pain and and shame and embarrassment
and it was in this dysfunctional thing
now both my parents are dead and I feel
like I'm starting life for the first
like starting from scratch and I
realized this the other day because I
was you know my sister and I have been
reunited we were separated at a very
young age I don't know if you even know
this totally because I had disassociated
or repressed it my sister and I we were
separated because it was such a abusive
situation we would we were running away
from home and we ran away from home when
we were
um like 11 and 12 respectively and lived
on this literally lived on the street
alone yeah and we're going Rehoboth
Beach and living in men's houses because
it was safer my mom finds me takes me to
live with my aunts who had never had
kids and I go to live with my aunts
we're separated and then in the my
parents divorce
have you ever heard of this no that you
know like in a divorce you say these
kids get you know uh the dad gets you
for weekends and the mom gets you
weekdays yeah they went dad gets Ashley
Mom gets Whitney
can you imagine separating your
daughters if you well no I just I just
go to the end you take them both I'll
just I'm gonna go to the beach yeah yeah
like whatever
I feel like it's already in writing I've
got it well we you know we said that to
our girls not to distract I want to hear
that story but I said to the girls one
time if Mom and I said two things I said
if Mom and I were going to prison
tomorrow who would you live with and
then all of a sudden it's silent when
like guys answer they're both in car
seats I go guys we have an answer and we
hear Georgia whimpering are you going to
prison and we're like no no maybe we
just thought no words
and they go it's just a question it's
not real oh boy isn't it
[Music]
that was a fucking joke because it's not
funny so then one day I said to the
girls I said if Mom and I split up who
would you want to live with they go mom
immediately and I go okay and they're
like right I go you don't ask me why did
you pick Mom and they go cuz
I we just want to stay in our rooms and
I went okay you don't want to stay in
your new rooms at my house and they're
like wait where are you living I go you
know I didn't ask and like where are you
living I said
in Malibu and they're like well you're
living in Malibu no no no stay with Mom
you're having fun I'll feed the horses
and they go you're getting horses I go
I'm getting lots of horses and you can
ride them on the beach in Malibu and
they're like wait you can I go no no you
picked mom you picked mom have fun doing
homework but you can live with Dad and
blow it all off and ride horses and
they're like wait hold on ask the
question again ask the question again
man I fucked up as a parent I did some
really stupid stuff can I just say
really quick this is so funny to me that
you think that this would go this way
because I want to talk to your daughters
and go hey you know they're uh Malibu
there's no Wi-Fi and you know that the
way you lost
you know that the electricity goes out I
went to Avril uh Avril Lavigne's
Thanksgiving two years ago I love Avril
Lopez she's the greatest
um you do you know that she we lost her
for four years because of Lyme disease
she had
Lyme disease I don't know
which by the way we need to talk about
big lime why is a lemon big lime as in
as in the people running
so lemons are this big okay the size of
a fist they're 25 cents they yield all
the yummy lemony shit in the world right
yeah a lime is the size of a fucking
quarter it's four dollars is it that
much better I have not I have not no
it's a right we'll talk birth controls a
racket limes I'm coming for limes uh
maple syrup more expensive than gasoline
really maple syrup is one of the most
expensive things you can get maple syrup
has a tremendous amount of minerals in
it so in the master cleanse I don't yeah
don't eat anything except remember
lemonade cayenne pepper maple syrup
because you can live off maple syrup for
like two weeks or some shit but that's
not why it's more expensive what is it
now which is Canadians it's harder to
get it's harder to get you don't have
any trees left no no no I mean have you
ever seen it's actually actually pretty
fascinating come on just come on repeat
let's just break the third wall and get
me a glass of wine Maples shortage
prices I heard eggs are apparently six
dollars we're talking 12 12 for maple
syrup this big 24 something this big how
winter rather may impact maple syrup
Supply well when Byron Allen came on the
podcast I highly recommend having them
on your podcast I would love to buy
Ronaldo my podcast he just literally
says the most interesting shit you've
ever heard it was the only time I've had
someone on podcast where I like didn't
interrupt them or talk
oh wow I put me to that challenge you're
telling me I won't interrupt Byron Allen
let's do it I interrupt how about this
how about this I told Amanda what's the
name what's the lady the Amanda Knox I I
told her the machine story
[Laughter]
a woman who's literally in prison for
murder in Italy for like fucking four
years it would have to restart itself
and I said when I was 22 years old I got
popularizing Papi and she went really I
know you've never heard the story and I
the fucking machine Story That's how
little I listen come on over Byron I
can't wait to see this interview because
you know Byron Allen he bought the
Weather Channel in cash which means he
has access to the the real scientists
okay not not you know your favorite
YouTuber who pretends to be a scientist
so he was saying I was like so what's
going on with global war like just jump
and he was like uh well what they're
telling me is there will be a global
food shortage very soon because Russia
has like half the world's fertilizer so
this we're gonna basically all the real
scientists that don't have time to start
podcasts
that are really doing just science all
day they're stocking up on canned food
because because we're going to start
having food for very real food shortages
they talk about global warming and they
say that what's going to happen is that
paces places like also who's they we
gotta we gotta follow on YouTube this uh
they say that that uh
is he non-binary is that what you call
him they
that's what he asked me to call him he's
they they he
she she said I don't see gender Albert I
don't see oh my God
I've said that one time and someone goes
she just suck any dick oh wait yeah wait
no no no I don't see gender I never
learned how to count okay
um I said that I said that I used to say
this as a like a throwaway joke
everybody like people go my buddy's
dyslexic
and then there's there's always Rumors
in comedy about what Comics I'm very
dyslexic I was very dyslexic I'm
dyslexia it means it's it it basically
just means you're better than everyone
anyway and so there's always rumors
about Comics that can't read right
because because teleprompter shows up
and then like there's very few can you
bleep out a name
uh just or just yeah
I'll just believe it because because
hold on
this whole thing we're going can we cut
this later Billy bush
okay
he the that thing where he said the
Trump thing yeah fingering audio that
was on a hot mic that they had a private
conversation 20 like 15 years after they
had it someone that worked there saved
it and went I'm gonna need a retirement
plan no oh my gosh you totally fucking
right so so don't put me in a situation
where the two people in this room I love
you both and I would take a bullet for
you but I'm not going to pretend that
Bert saying some hot gossip won't be
worth a million dollars to TMZ in 10
years and guess what if you you Pat has
children if you don't use some shit that
I said that could cancel me to make a
million dollars for your two daughters
that I love to send them to college I'm
gonna lose respect for you I feel like I
say crazy shit on here on purpose just
for you to cut and put in the bank later
to know that you have a retirement plan
okay anyway what else about man clip it
use it send your kids to college
I have I have a couple stories about
that I never realized that I remember
what was the
the necessary you can't read let's go
meaning
I don't know I don't know
no no no no no no no I don't want to be
Associated
just brought up a community and said
this comedian can't read a teleprompter
and he told me it was I go that comedian
doesn't show up to work you can't read a
teleprompter if you don't get out of bed
and get to the set make sure you cannot
hear the name because I don't want to
get involved in that fucking
Stratosphere but but that person can
read when it comes to like uh how much
money they're gonna make at a gig
they're not gonna show up to yeah yeah
well so we were talking about we were
with it was with Shane girls and Mark
Norman and then you know what I almost
had uh was gonna ask Mark Norman to host
your roast oh and we did Trevor Wallace
instead of a reason Wallace did a
fantastic because I really wanted to
like mix you know and then it was like
all the moving pieces and then I was
gonna go oh why don't I just have Mark
Norman's just be on it and then it was
like starting to be too many people and
then I was just like oh like it was
almost Mark Norman Trevor Wallace did a
family
the next morning I wish Mark Norman had
been on the roast and I was working so
hard to figure out how and then he had a
Torah conflict and then anyway so anyway
normally I think I think Norman is
taking risks that I that a lot of people
are not taking Donald made me laugh so
fucking hard because he because he goes
there's a joke I think it's in there and
he goes do you know what I have Bert
saved in as my phone and I and there's a
moment and Leanne is Leanne's favorite
part of the roast that I think is that
there's a there's such a good story and
he was like and he knows that's knocking
out and he's like no no no no no it was
so fun I love Donnell to death Donella
was also but
you know people that were really good
friends were sitting next to each other
rigid and scared and roasting each other
like to see you and Dot now being that
you know like I wanted to just create a
and I hate the word safe space because
it fucking it's been stolen by dorks
yeah uh you know what I mean it's like
it's like rainbows like no men can't get
you know gay people I love you guys you
took the rainbow no I still love
rainbows man men can't have rainbows
anymore like a five-year-old child like
I have a friend um who's you know has a
kid and uh
and the boy is like has rainbows I'm
like and they're like rainbow like he's
not gay let's just hold it's a rain just
hold on kids can't boy kids can't like
rainbows or they're coming out of the
closet is gay at two if they think a
rainbow is cool like don't bring that
conversation up to my dad because oh my
dad's in Florida and I guess to Santos I
don't know I don't know anything about
politics but my dad said that desantos
is uh like they're they're they're doing
like uh from I don't know I don't even
fucking know and by the way I don't know
and I don't know if my dad's entirely
accurate I mean that's a different thing
I think you're what you're I think can't
say gay or something if you could maybe
not compare me to uh to Santos okay I
won't I won't but you know what they'll
actually do it maybe my um maybe I would
start selling out Arenas selling tickets
at the Emily Center Amelie Arena I might
start being able to you know selling out
the Smoothie King or yeah the Smoothie
King in uh in New Orleans will be there
for in July for fully loaded do you know
that in the roast I said like the you
know in my set for you like I'm not
trying to make fun of the difference
between men and women in comedy because
you've also been doing it so much longer
than me but
I've been doing it I've been doing it 22
years how long you been doing comedy 18.
okay now I feel
like how long have you been doing comedy
when you start 2004
yeah
you started 2004 right I should be
selling more tickets by now wait what
are you talking about my narrative was
Bert's like 20 years has been doing this
like 20 years longer than me oh no no no
we're peers
Whitney if you if you didn't if you
didn't have two sides of your brain so
this is my fault it's on me if you
didn't have two sides of your brain if
you had just one brain that didn't think
of all the other things again now you
just activated the other side of my
brain like what do I do to Celtic no but
you would you would be doing what I
would I all I do is comedy that's it I
don't make TV shows I don't sell yeah
yeah I will bring me in and pull my
focus and go can you run this show and
then you have to shut down every side of
your brain and just do that and you have
to take time off to be okay so I have
been doing comedy probably 16 years but
there's like
set yeah five years in there I was
totally only doing TV only doing TV and
by the way in that five years that's
when I was making that's when
that's when comedy got to where it is
today because a bunch of us had to go do
bullshit clubs for bullshit money and
got really good at stand up and and
that's when you were making Whitney you
were making Two Broke Girls you were you
were selling and everything writing
movies and that's when all of us didn't
we didn't we don't have that ability and
you know it's a while though is that the
people who were I'm gonna just say this
and it's because obviously you guys are
the winners so I can say the people that
were rejected by Hollywood are the ones
that are winning the hardest now because
you look at like you know like Jo koi
fluffy and you're like oh they didn't
have the sitcoms they didn't have the TV
shows they didn't even have networks
buying their specials so they had to
make them theirself and then cut to now
they own their own audio they own their
specials they could put it on Spotify
they could put I don't own any of my the
things I made because a network paid for
it because they did accept me I thought
they were accepting me and I was gonna
be set forever and I went oh this is the
way to make it it's really fascinating
and then the industry changed now now
everything I've ever made is owned by
Viacom and HBO I can't even get it back
I can't put it on my channels I cannot
put four of my specials because the one
I just did I paid for myself on Spotify
raw dog I don't own it yeah I have to
buy it back Sebastian Maniscalco he did
three specials that were not done you
know uh that he owns so he could sell
them he could sell them to Amazon he can
sell them so it's like the people that
made it in Hollywood
uh 10 years ago are the most behind now
it's it's a very interesting statement
because I often think in comedy sorry
he's selling out baseball fields he
owned his own shit yeah and was able to
go direct to Consumer for now how about
let the entertainers decide how people
are gonna get entertained because we
know more about how people get
entertained than you people do not want
to go on a first date like let's go
watch for a Chrysler come here we're
going on a first date I'm asking
hey Pete ask me on a date to go see the
Bert Chrysler movie hey Whitney would
you like to go on a date
yes how how where where is it
I don't know so oh can we go you have a
whoop band I was so close to fucking you
um
like do you really yeah
hold on what band P do you really not
know how you slept do you need a science
he's got issues with it do you because
he goes because you know every time it's
in the green I feel tired every time
it's in the yellow I feel energized but
I just don't let me just let me just may
I no no
don't break Georgia
oh in that case okay I know and look and
um uh Leanne gave me this bracelet so
here we go well I got nothing from my
wife no but I'm sorry Bert got me this
morning
I got this watch you got me this
bracelet thank you so the what band this
is men in LA are wearing a science
bracelet that tells them how they slept
last night how many calories they burn
and then they expect us to want to fuck
them and it's hard because if you don't
know how you slept last night how can I
trust you with anything do you wake up
in the morning and go like can anyone
what happened what just happened
what like I couldn't tell you
sometimes so so so you know that this
this people are complaining the robots
are taking their jobs so um something
that tells you how you slap something
that tells you how you ate today that's
called a girlfriend or a wife uh Peter's
never been in love this uh bracelet is
but you're making it so a woman has no
purpose for you
so so you and I are together so you're
you let's say we're in love let's wake
up together this is how it goes ah
we're waking up
oh I feel like I didn't sleep that good
dude I feel like I was tossing and
turning what I think you slept you
definitely was you were you were up you
were up you were down
how we used to do it
I would do this I put a finger on your
neck you're making it so so don't do
this because then now women do that no
women do this do that women have no
reason to touch you go baby what's my
heart rate so I'm just curious why the
science bracelet like what do you need
from the what band because I I I did do
a corporate gig uh a week ago last
weekend where I am
I kind of like was off on the assignment
it was all every billionaire in the
world uh the creator of this the creator
of everything went up to Park City wrote
20 pages of Rose jokes roasted them to
their face it went poorly
um
and but it was you know I did I did it
last year and it went great right but
this year like there were the kushners
were there and Saudis were there and it
was like it was not the same like you
know because like Saudi money is is
starting to own Hollywood and it's not
is it a bad thing I don't know changed
the script I wrote yesterday was it by
the way was it better because I don't
know when people were like oh Saudi
money is buying Hollywood I'm like okay
well when Saudi money wasn't involved uh
this business was built on the back of a
five-year-old toddler named Shirley
Temple so it can't get worse was it
really Shirley Temple I mean she she
she was a toddler a sexy toddler like it
was crazy that she'd walk around
businessmen going it's the good hey Chef
hey mister it's the Good Ship she's
she's twerking on men's lot there's no
not a mom in sight not a babysitter
she's literally at War dancing for the
soldiers like in these movies can you
hold on have you ever seen Shirley
Temple in blackface I'm Googling it
right now have you ever seen it it's
it's a it's called I want to say it's uh
this is by the way and what I'll say is
whoever did this uh must be related to
Trudeau's blackface guy because it is so
perfectly applied yeah well let me tell
you how it happens so hold on I don't
even know how it happens I'm going to
check the whoop band it'll tell me wait
didn't me and you text about this at one
point probably but I'm but I'm just
saying this has been an obsession of
mine because I think I'm at a point Bert
I think we've talked about this oddly
enough probably me and you were texting
back and forth because I watched this
movie we didn't text I think we might
have talked about it maybe on your
podcast I did talk about it on Rogan
once because I think we're all in this
moment where we're going okay we're
Comics we have opportunities our uh
comedy fans want to see us in movies
they want to see us in TV shows but
we're kind of like feel weird about
Hollywood people and we don't trust them
that much but we want to make TV shows
so do we have to do these deals with the
devil so for me I think on some level I
got really good at TV so I could go
Comics we need a comic Comics shouldn't
work with people that uh I'm not saying
they shouldn't work with people that
aren't Comics but the position work with
people that don't get Comics that's it
because and that don't respect us that
um to handcuff us uh that think that
we're uh that think that we're just like
these idiot children that they have to
Wrangle
um and so and allow us to trust our
instincts and then and then trust our
instincts also we know what's funny you
guys eyes we know what's funny we have
been I've been to Penguins Pittsburgh
every year have you and then they tell
you what's relatable they tell you what
America's gonna get you have an idea as
a comic you go and they go yeah but is
that relatable
I think I think the things it's a show
that makes fun of poor people it's funny
show yeah or they they couldn't do the
office now but if we go in and try to
tell networks this is what we know is
funny because we're out there in the
trenches and we have a direct line to
the fans and they go yeah but maybe you
should be a firefighter
you're a beer salesman and I'm like on
the NBC sitcom Whitney I just wanted to
do like exactly what I was doing it was
like it was about being in a
relationship with with a guy that had
money and I didn't want to take any of
his money because I grew up poor and I
didn't I don't want anything I don't
deserve and I don't want anything I
didn't earn yeah right and then it's
pretty spot on the Whitney
I don't want anything I don't deserve
you know and so the character is like
by the way hey Bert she deserves so much
more a little bit more
foreign
she deserves way more homes
more diamond bracelets yes yes from you
and but I think that like now it's like
we're in this weird situation you're
doing movies
like I want to get back into TV I just
am not gonna let have a bunch of people
that went to school for advertising tell
me what people in Nebraska I wore the
shirt for you Nebraska shirt that's
where I shot my special people in uh
Omaha think is funny because you guys
have never been to Omaha you won't visit
and you think everyone that lives there
is stupid it's crazy everyone said to me
we don't think that what you guys do
they said why would you shoot it in
Omaha and I said are you being serious
as have you ever been to Omaha it's a
pretty cool place and and there's great
fans and they're comedy fans they've
been Colleen Quinn has created a comedy
community in Omaha Nebraska that great
Comics going to Great comics from all
walks in life do you know the do you
know how great the comedy fans are in
Nebraska they're fucking amazing do you
know of course you just shot yourself do
you know the Larry the Cable Guy Story
the Fourth of July no so Larry the Cable
Guy from Omaha right yeah lives just
outside of Ohio yeah this was I don't
know when this was corroborated someone
tell me if I'm wrong on the details
um uh uh but I think about this a lot he
was when he was touring when Larry the
Cable Guy was touring like big when they
were doing you know baseball fields in
arenas and you know whatever
he was so popular he was touring the 4th
of July uh was the only date he had free
and he was trying to slot in doing Omaha
to do a coming home show so he said the
only day I can do is the fourth of July
so they had him come perform on the
fourth of July and they rescheduled
America's birthday to the fifth they
moved the fireworks to the fifth so that
Larry the Cable Guy could perform on
July 4th
they moved America's birthday so that
they could go see comedy
they rescheduled they pushed it they
pushed the fireworks they've pushed the
fireworks
and everyone was like that's a good
choice
we'd rather laugh and we'll celebrate
the birth of America tomorrow all I
could hear in this story was how much
fun do you think a Fourth of July show
could be
I think you got to do it pretty early or
not no who actually want that's actually
a really good point I feel like for some
reason like as Comics it's like New
Year's Eve I'm always working
Valentine's Day always working big night
before the July for some reason I feel
like people just want to see fireworks
you do it in a stadium right now here's
the thing you should do a thing where we
do come see fireworks and come see
comedians get fired from their jobs
we'll say something that gets us fired
oh yeah yeah we'll we'll set off
fireworks on stage bring up Mark Norman
he'll fucking murder he'll fucking kill
that's Alicia Fourth of July we should
do like an annual uh Fourth of July like
fireworks show that's just people
blowing up their careers he met he met
uh Guy Fieri at my house and that's not
how you pronounce it that's how you
pronounce it Guy Fieri Guy Fieri
no yep that's how you pronounce it
he's
icebergs how do you say this stuff that
they pour cement cement
okay my last name is Cummings I can't
say semen any more than I already have
to cement right cement concrete cement
crayon Crown
also you know what I did recently I was
with uh uh my friend Dan Levy's daughter
and we were playing with crayons and I
was like where's the where's the nude
crayon
oka's nude remember beige used to be
nude
nude meant white person it is not wild
and then my sister my sister no my
sister's back in my life so I just say
her name all the time what do they call
the Yellow crayon
yellow yellow
you're just coward you're just a cow
called the Coldplay crayon I don't know
but also uh was it uh Girl Scouts so I
don't know uh no it's uh they still call
them that girl scouts because Girl
Scouts so Dan's wife is uh Dan Levy good
friend of mine comic uh I always every
year I just buy all the Girl Scout
cookies because Girl Scouts it's
basically making the mom have to work
and sell these cookies it's now it's
just it's such a rack Samoas some that's
my favorite girl My Favorite Girl Scout
Cookie by far by far I think the Girl
Scouts need to be shut down immediately
the whole thing is just making moms have
to do more jobs to sell cookies well we
I just brought I just bought cookies you
know what how about this girl scouts I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you something teach
them how to cook teach him how to make
cookies teach him how to do something
except get the thing and then sell it in
a little mini skirt and like flirt with
strangers it's a weird thing to teach
kids how to do teach them skills I was
in the Girl Scouts okay yeah I was in
the Girl Scouts we didn't pay the bills
and I got sent home and I couldn't
afford the patches and all that shit I
had to draw them on myself it's the
whole thing but
I
at 26 years old
first time I was able to afford a car
okay after I did a uh uh I got you know
thirty thousand dollars the first time
I've ever made that kind of money I did
a campaign with Lexus and that was like
and I went and I they gave me a discount
and I was able to 26 years old I Byron
Allen had fixed my credit uh because I
couldn't get rent anything get it
because I didn't have credit and then I
was able to get a hybrid Lexus yeah
within 24 hours of having the Lexus I
filled it up with diesel fuel
destroyed the car
no why was I in Girl Scouts and no one
told me the difference between and I and
I went oh this is a hybrid yeah the
nozzle is green I'm gonna use the green
nozzle let's and you say that because
Leanne I was a Girl Scout Troop leader
and she brought all the Girl Scouts to
wadawi Alabama and taught them stuff
about like how to I mean first of all
they learn a lot about camping but
taught them a lot of stuff with her her
father but why till 27 did I think a
401k was a marathon
they didn't teach you they didn't teach
you like shit I actually needed to know
well back then yeah of course of course
it's a racket it's
children and pretending to make women
strong I think it's changed okay call
Dan Levy's wife okay what's her name
okay I'll do it right now hold on
where's uh Pat don't freak out and in
the meantime I'm going to show you
something that I'm working on uh because
I can't not solve problems that no one
asked me to solve okay to save my life
uh I want to start a new girl scouts
I like this already and okay I want to
start a new girl scouts that teaches
them skills they actually need right
like the come on the tits thing
I've started collecting pins to start my
own Girl Scout uh troop for my friends
kids and we're gonna start doing it at
my house every Sunday I love this and
we're gonna do it with horses we're
gonna do wolf therapy Equine Therapy
like do you realize how many kids would
love like if you said to my daughters
Whitney's starting a Girl Scout Troop
who would you like to go over to her
house and and have have your Sunday
there they would fucking love it I'm
gonna like we're gonna be like you're
rescuing bees out of the pool so this
we're learning learning how to uh uh
keep your own beehives remember the at
your house we're gonna put in Milkweed
to restore the Monarch population yes
and then for that you're gonna get the
sunflower pin for doing that I'm gonna
teach you guys how to give blow jobs for
like with no teeth I'm
but this is like you know that uh
cutting avocados it's one of the main
injuries in LA in the ER it's called
avocado hand people cut avocados and put
the knife through their hand I'm going
to teach you how to cut an avocado
without cutting your hand off and then
you're gonna get this pen the avocado
pin I have a fight with a woman at a
party about an avocado
do tell
she was also what party I can't picture
gray really nice house
and the woman was cutting out party
whose party uh some uh some guy was
looking after the house so it was a
really nice house but no one lived there
just recently this was when Lynn and I
were just maybe we had Georgia maybe we
didn't I don't remember a long time ago
but I but she uh was peeling the avocado
with a knife
and and then and I and I said and I
thought it was Leanne and I go you're
doing that wrong and she went excuse me
and I said oh I'm sorry I thought you
were my wife she goes you thought you
were I was your wife and I said yeah she
goes well I feel sorry for your wife
that you'd correct her in doing
something I said I feel sorry for your
husband you don't know how to build an
avocado
and then and the uh and and but she
didn't know how to I mean how do you not
know how to peel an office so just so
everyone knows you take the knife you
put it in you run it around the seed you
go like this and then run around and
grab it and then run around then you
split it in half then pop the knife the
edge of the knife into the avocado seed
have you done this when something's
burning no you should do a whole episode
just like avocado toast I love the first
Kevin James introduced me to avocados I
never had an avocado in my life until I
met Kevin James
we were at uh that's how that's how
how
um we're talking about white privilege I
mean no it's
it's this is how and I think I'm
learning this more and more like
comedians because you know our job is to
be relatable our job you know there's
things about us that are very odd in
some ways we're like now remember the
movie now
wait
is it the fact that you've never
experienced an avocado before meeting
Kevin James like like that's not a
normal like I'm struggling a little bit
going like oh with my background like I
don't know how to play gin rummy I don't
know how to play chess oh my God oh my
God oh my God no one taught me how about
this I haven't seen Goonies
like like we have these blind spots that
I think a lot of people don't have
because number one we've been on the
road for 20 years trying to make
strangers laugh and we haven't gotten to
hang out at parties and like I'm not
like I realize like I'm not socialized
like I don't know how to play chess to
play
name a card like and I get embarrassed
and I don't want to people to think I
don't know or who am I going to get to
teach me I can't like I almost want to
ask my assistant like can you help me
learn card games so I can go to parties
and not look like in like an idiot like
I don't know how to play Pictionary like
I don't know the rules it it it's I'm
not trying to like it sounds sad we
found a new we found a new game called
uh banana
and it's one of the funnest
car because I want to learn how to play
card games really because because what
happens when because and I'm like oh I
don't have any hobbies all I do is work
like obviously and still you know those
are overrated but they are well the
problem is every time I I get a hobby I
turn it into a business me too I took up
leather working and look and look I
literally after
view yeah do you know that I'm gonna
start um I'm gonna start welding
and then and then immediately you're
gonna figure out how to make jewelry
jewelry okay watch it watch this and
then sell it at your shows yeah that
makes sense
it but I'll also because what it is is I
have all these like things once your
parents die there's all these like
Family Jewels and stuff but I don't want
to wear my mom's engagement ring from
the most cursed marriage ever so funny I
had a an engagement ring almost
identical to that that I found at
SeaWorld a long time first of all foxy
world back when you could go to SeaWorld
before the thing
you you jumped in your own pool just
when you it was just killing trainers
that's it that was all it was just that
by the way people were like but the
whales are happy the second that bitch
had a ponytail she was dead yup he was
waiting to kill her
for years secret time secret time secret
time hardcore time foxy world we did uh
we did a an integration with SeaWorld
for Travel Channel and they're like uh
they're like hey man uh first of all it
was funny shit it was fun and shit but
I'm sure the animals we didn't know we
didn't know we've been you know we
thought child labor was normal at one
point no we all we knew at the time the
knew it we knew at the time and they
said hey we need you to put on a um put
on a wetsuit and it was a Sea World of
the stomach you can Google it you can
find me and SeaWorld outfit and I put it
on and everyone in the crew is like oh I
go what the F1 guy goes it's like you're
wearing a Nazi uniform like it really
because they're the bad guys I mean you
gotta blazing on your chest see if you
can find me in a Sea World outfit I
swear to God and I was like but I had so
much fun playing with the fucking I know
walruses like fucking screwed me around
the pool it's rough oh here you are I
got him hold on
and then see
actually I'm not as fat as I am now you
know avocado hand
when someone tries to cut an avocado
it may go straight through their hand
secret time yeah been there
been there I don't know the avocado look
at that with a vitamin with the vitamin
E tablet
okay I had a I had a vitamin E tablet
but you can see it right here this is
the scar you can see it right there I
had a vitamin E tablet right there I was
working for Animal Planet vitamin E
that's like the only vitamin I've never
heard of vitamin E is a is really you
don't need to eat it you can break them
open and put it on yourself okay I know
it topically I didn't know about it okay
yeah so I have the tablet right there
I'm on ecstasy we're about to go get
drinks and and I go let me just I got
sunburned let me put this on and I have
a wine opener so I have the little thing
the little blade on the wide opener
through my hand uh pokes out this side
but does not go through it doesn't go
all the way through it and my favorite
line out of that I go into the hospital
and I showed her what happened she goes
oh how did that happen I go stigmata
she goes Stigmata and I went I know I
didn't believe it either so but can you
guess anybody that was so fucking
painful it was so painful the hand
because also that reminds me of remember
when um uh uh uh David Blaine went on
Rogan's uh podcast and he did the thing
where he the magic trick where he puts
like a what a sword or what is this a
pokey thing a needle a large needle
through his hands oh what a brilliant
move to do magic tricks on a podcast
remember people can't see them and you
go watch okay are you guys listening I'm
gonna show Whitney a podcast right now
you ready
so for those who listen I got a magic
trick I'm gonna show with you okay watch
this
I am about to disappear
by the count of three you'll no longer
see me okay
three two one
whoa whoa where's Burr
whoa oh dude we are sleeping on why do
we hate money burnt why aren't we
podcast magicians
in half
because that's where the real shit is
because the human imagination makes it
way better I don't know why they're not
doing porn podcasts
all right
let's have sex you ready okay okay ready
okay hold on wait hold on
hold on I do want to say I have all this
lingerie here that I brought out for you
guys these are your bras hold on let me
make sure it's been used because
sometimes thank you thank you sometimes
you wear underwear in a sexual situation
okay they smell phenomenal people
but here's the thing even when I buy
sexy lingerie it is these like muted
tones it is these like you know what the
nude crayon made an imprint on me as a
child I I include crayon because I this
is my attempt to be like look at me I'm
just I'm just uh like like this was my
attempt to get like the Caddyshack set
like look at me I'm just a little I like
the Candy Stripes I like that they go
they go bigger in the butt but why do I
think this is this color flesh color is
section oh my God can I borrow those for
for a while take them to Liam those are
fucking hot as shit give me these but
hold on God damn it this is like that's
the one I grabbed first okay and then
this one but hold on but there's one
this is not this is a this is like for a
cancer no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no that bra is that
bra is an event bra this is this this is
where I shine okay this is what I think
is supposed is like like I think with
lingerie I think you guys want to get it
off so fast
it's an eighth grade mistake but hold on
my new thing is just wear lingerie that
you don't take off at all that's the
that's that's where you so this guy
right you want that right that thing
let me see what's your heart rate on
your whoop band did it go up did it go
up no I think you got it I think that's
your mistake with the wolf band is that
this is going to tear uh people apart if
you and I are dating and I come out in
lingerie I want to go let me see your
what band
or when a hot girl walks by I want to go
let me see your whoopin do you realize I
I I I'm gonna say this to you honestly
do you realize what she'd do for your
life first of all you got a great
girlfriend right great girlfriend but
she wakes up every morning telling you
this is how we fix you Pete first of all
we're getting rid of this bucket hat
yeah let's let's throw some uh VO5 Hot
Oil Treatment in that hair but the
bucket hat there's more going on under
the bucket hat what do you mean there's
something like when people have a thing
that they do that it's like you're like
that's a wild choice there's something
else going on the the moment there's
like you don't want to do your hair you
do you have a thing does it is it
because it's raining that you're wearing
the bucket hat no I'll tell you what it
is your frizzy hair yeah there's a
reason for the bucket hat the the second
I I would I would give my earnings for
fully loaded which are going to be
meager because I pay for I pay for a lot
of other people and you're paying me way
too much I I owe you my earnings
for the moment you broke him and he told
you what he thinks and feels because
Pete is very very life about life Pete
is very closed up can I tell you
something Bert please
you're his boss
am I not supposed to do that no no
you wouldn't know
no I live with the guy I live with the
guy I know but but do you really want to
hear your assistance like hardships I
kind of know some of them but what but
that's like a weird it's like it's I'm
realizing because oh no no no you and I
are cool bosses like like literally I
hang like I hire people I want to be
friends with okay let me and then I go
yeah let's talk about your childhood and
I think they're kind of like well you're
my boss so like we've we've never really
worked with professional professional
bosses in a lot of ways and I think that
he might be super emotionally stunted
and not be able to talk about his
feelings but even if he could it'd be
weird to do it with his boss I don't
want him to do with me what I want what
I want I want to be there in the morning
in my gym where I'm working out and P
shows up 15 minutes late and as clear
has been crying all night and he comes
in and he goes no no what how does it
how is it clear because what band told
him he cried what band told him it's
like yo you're dehydrated you cried all
night and then he comes in and he goes
fucking with me man
we set up by our fireplace and I mean it
was like fucking amazing I mean I I
think wait hold on let's not go through
them so fast okay but this is my bet
this is not a good batch of bras and
sexy lingerie I think I have a better
batch somewhere I'll find them uh but I
think I think that's the
what's the fucking string thing I'll
tell you this what is it looks like okay
I have to be honest here's what I'm good
at hold on I'm really we will okay give
me the string tip one wait this one
this one is oh I stopped reaching around
my fucking chest well you can adjust it
uh Whitney
Winnie let's see if it reaches let's
make sure we don't uh David Carradine
Bert Kreischer right now but this it's
fixing it oh my God this bird has I knew
why the bras came out bird was looking
for an excuse to take his shirt off now
we have it so what if I got a bra
sponsor here's the
this is as much as you helped me I
thought you were putting it on me well
you're sorry that you're wearing my
merch his hat has uh a photo of a
painting of meter and the pandemic on it
oh my God wait hold up hold up can you
wait do I need to go over my shoulders
by the way look how warm this is do you
see all the like deodorant and powder on
it oh you know me dudes fuck you in this
okay and I'm wearing it wait wait put it
on my back put it around my back yeah
I'm sweating it when I got sued by our
friend are you serious see if you can go
no the this bird no this is this is
but it looks good like this but why
I see why now
so this is birth control for men women
fuck you this is me walking out of
Whitney's bedroom it didn't go the way
it plans I swear to God
can I just tell you like remember like
how I just said well it's so aggressive
what does it smell like it smells like
sex it does smells like good smells like
good smells
oh yeah that smells like the um the
perfume I wear when I'm Ready for War
when I need to like asphyxiate a man
this is pretty that's hot as shit that's
very awesome so here's the thing so
here's what I want this is like a good
opportunity because if you didn't think
this is like crocodile hunter shit but
you just grabbing it by the tail seeing
if it bites me
but like if you didn't know about the
cum on my face please don't cover my
pussy so I don't have to be on birth
control or whatever it is
can you just picture
a woman putting lingerie like before
you're about to go out and have sex I
just want you to know it's like I'm
gonna go have sex with this guy I have a
house I have a big business I need to
make sure he feels like the man right
that's I use lingerie to make myself
seem less Whitney coming less powerful
submissive little girl interesting I
just had to start buying ropes oh these
are socks hold on
I started buying these black ropes I'm
like do you need to hang me from a noose
like what do you need to do to make me
like a tiny little baby that's not gonna
emasculate you so I'm like just in my
bathroom like
I'm like I send an email that's the
thing because you do a message I sent an
email that's like let's wire birth that
50 Grand and then I'll da da da da and
then I'm doing all my business then I'm
like
here we go time to put on the uniform
tape over my face and I'm like
like tiny and
uh Beta And I use lingerie to do that so
I do that I do that but hang on lingerie
is going who
is the little tiny
question oh that's exactly I can't tell
you that's exactly what I was thinking
so this is me with so that's why it is
the 50s I go 50s I go 50. I think guys
like that because that was a better
that's when women were behaving how they
should behave
this makes me go oh don't worry I I
don't think I'm supposed to be running
TV shows I'm used to be in the kitchen
skirt making
I don't know anything about cooking fun
making
making the cookies making it uh the I
literally thought about something's
burning the caviar I think I'm just
whipping up a little bit I'm just doing
the pork roast in the kitchen where I
belong who me so it's like um by the way
you can catch this on the show you just
caught me sneaking a beat going oh yeah
yeah keep going with me anyway I think
part if if Bert finds this bra look
attractive right now it's only because
the name of the city the state of the
city he did to the special and is a part
of is this more it's almost more
it's almost more you know it would be
crazy I think I have to do because of
whatever my personality is and Bert I'm
glad we're talking about this and this
isn't a tangent because there's been a
couple times I've been on your podcast
or I've done something that's burning
the Tim Dillon episode you bring it up
or you're like what's it like dating you
I think everyone wants to know well yeah
and I never answered it I think about
that all the time because you are
you're a Powerhouse of a human and
meaning that every time I'm around you
you change the way I think change the
way I feel you change the way I run my
business and I go like God damn it you
mean I remember Leanne there's a secret
time secret to secret time I won't say
the whole thing okay I'll say that I'll
say the whole thing but Leanne goes
I won't say the whole thing but I will
say the half of it the first time I
think it was the first time you like
hung out with me and Leanne and the
girls we're in the front yard and uh
I'll say this was at the old the
previous house yeah I'll say the whole
thing uh but but give me the option to
take it out why are you pretending
you're not gonna overshare I'm gonna
overshare but I'm not but I'm on the
fence because I don't wanna I know I
don't yeah but but this is also can I
just say what this is why you were
chosen uh uh doing the roast with you
and why we were able to do the roast
this way because you're you just watched
a comedian be a good person and not want
to hurt anyone yeah you know what I mean
we feel guilt we feel it's like of with
Chris Rock before he got punched in the
face and no one stood up he was
backstage going is that too far is that
too far I shouldn't say that let me just
do the fucking GI Jane joke we're not
monsters we're not punching down we're
not animals this is how we feel when
we're like should I say it no no I don't
want to we are very respectful when we
disrespect someone yeah
I want to I just even if we cut the
story out I want to show the moment of
going I know you guys think that we're
just like throwing grenades and we're
just like we uh uh perseverate
constantly read such a great fucking
word I per separate non-fucking stop
because I'm a person because we're in
fear should I say this should I not say
this I don't want to hurt anyone he's
going I don't want to hurt someone but I
want to
want to keep everyone that's the fucking
thing that catches me up is I go I I
don't know this is okay I literally have
a uh sorry like a rope around my neck
sorry let's just um I was just paying
homage to Anthony Bourdain apologies
one of my favorite things like like
having you on the roast and we'll get
back to your story that you may or may
not tell but that was a beautiful moment
because I just want people to see that
that you're bullying comedian like we
just want to make people laugh and we
are the life of the party and when we
hurt some or disrespect someone or say
something negative we're going how do we
do how do I hurt nobody but make
everybody laugh yeah and well it's my in
the special I have now I I have a joke
in there that Isla
wanted me to take out 100 or 10 grand
for it so I'll give you 10 grand if you
if it's so funny I took my I put my tits
up and you put yours on off we literally
you just put
I uh I uh
but I I I I I I don't run the risk I do
it I I
bulldoze people I have a big wake and I
don't think twice about things and I I
over share horrifically our job is to
kind of humiliate ourselves hurt
ourselves you're going out there and
hurting yourself you know you're sort of
like the roasts are verbal MMA right
that's why I love the rose so much it's
MMA but it's verbal but what we did that
that Comedy Central wasn't doing before
is we made sure that the people doing
the verbal MMA and the rose were in the
same weight class right only
heavyweights what they started doing is
heavy weights and featherweights that's
not fun to watch because someone's gonna
get hurt and we saw it with Pam Anderson
we saw it with all these people that
were on roast that were like I'm a
celebrity why is Greg Geraldo slam I'm a
famous actress why is Greg rolls but
that's what he was hired to do and he
can't put you know
Etc so that's why I think our roasts
were so fun because it was heavyweights
only yeah it was comics comics yeah no
one gets hurt so I was like very careful
about who I put on it and I think we're
similar in the way that like I only want
to do stand up if
uh the the people that come to see the
shows I want to be friends with them if
you think I what I just said was funny
we're buddies dude yeah when I see
Comics like they don't want to take
pictures with their fans they don't want
to talk to them I know I know I know a
couple Comics I know a couple Comics
that aren't fans of their fans why are
you doing material that's attracting
people that you don't want to be in the
same room uh I don't understand I think
it I think it eats them up I think I
know one guy I won't say that's my
nightmare that's amazing I talked to
naparazzi about this about a couple guys
a couple guys he was like yo what's so
crazy he's like this dot he like
literally legit hates his fans and I was
like really he was like yeah he's like
fucking crazy and and both of us how do
you get up in the morning to work hard
and I when I get on a plane if I'm doing
three connections to
you know St Louis or whatever it is the
only reason I get through it is because
I know the people are in that room are
going to be the coolest people in St
Louis to me they like me I think they're
cool my mean reason my daughters are
like I would never date one of your fans
I go I would hope you would they're
funny because they're all 65. yeah
no the Georgia as when she went to
college there were guys who were fans of
mine and I was like oh I wanted to say
the word they're the same lost dude I
was but can I say something about what
she's saying and I'm not I'm not I'm not
pretending to know what she meant yeah
but that also could have been like I
just I I want someone to love me for me
and not because I'm your daughter
oh
women it's so hard for us it's so hard
for us to find people that love us for
us and I think that's also a weird
little trapping of Fame that I didn't
anticipate which is like and I'm not
saying I'm so fairness whatever but it's
like I it didn't occur to me that I had
anything to offer anybody because my
self-esteem is so low I'm just this
piece of shit and then I was like oh
wait and then someone once told me like
well that guy you're dating he's like a
starfucker and like my first thought was
like
so I mean I'm a star
and then I realized like oh my god there
will and you're with someone I there I
will never be able maybe not ever
I will not be able to
um
have a pure connection I'll always
wonder why someone is with me I put
myself in a situation where I'll always
be used and Always Be Loved for
something that will always be a variable
and it's a weird little prison of your
own making that is so worth it it's
ridiculous yeah it's such a small price
to pay because we also we're the people
with the sharpest intuition so my
intuition will tell me if this is if
you're using me or not I just have to
turn my intuition on because I also come
from being used and treated like an ATM
machine so it's like I kind of feel okay
with that because it makes me think I'm
useful I'm you know that's my
codependent thing yeah and I think that
also my little and because I know you
love me for real and I love you for real
I owe you like some explanations on you
know in the last time I was on something
spurning you were like um so what
happened during the pandemic like I was
at my codependent bottom which is like I
was remember I was having comedians at
my house I was paying people's bills
because it was the pandemic and I was so
like to me when people in my life are
not financially secure I know how awful
that feels so I tried I just I'm like
well let me pay your debt let me take
care of your student loan let me do that
and I didn't realize how much that
toxifies a relationship even though
you're really just trying to give them
the gift of the freedom of not worrying
about money and that is a gift to me
because I was I had seven dollars for 10
years on Miller uh next to pink top and
I the fear you can't write jokes you
can't be fun on stage you can because I
I like to say to a comic like oh my God
you're so brilliant whatever if you
didn't have this debt hanging over you
imagine how great you would be on stage
yeah because you're not like you're able
to just be free like and so I tried to
give people that a lot of people that
freedom and it made my French it made me
um
I I lost the Purity it's like of
friendship which is you know one thing
to do in Equine Therapy is the first
thing you know people say when they want
to go develop a relationship with a
horse let's say they go let's go give it
carrots let's give it treats let me say
that's the worst thing you can do why
why should you never give a horse treats
if you're asking me because you
established uh it's like you're never
supposed to feed an alligator because
then they can't tell why where the
chicken stops and the Hand starts is
that not why I don't know why
I guess you can feed alligators
it's just like it's so fun to be in love
with a man
that I'm not sexually attracted to thank
you it's just like I it's just I haven't
had I have not had men in my life that
were good men I'm gonna say it I didn't
have a lot of data that men were like
this that any man could be like you and
uh you know I and then you basically in
your 20s at least in my case was
recreating my childhood circumstances
and just gravitating towards the same
kind of man yeah and then my data was
all men are like this when in real and I
would go all men do this no bitch all
the men you gravitated towards because
that was your major I did that with
dudes and dudes we do it with friends
too I did it with dudes I would I would
gravitate towards dudes who could take
liberties with me that uh I that I would
forgive and they would do things that
were a little aggressive do you make
excuses like oh but he's just having a
rough day he's going through a divorce
Well yeah if you want to get by in
comedy you just let them hat let it
happen or like who am I to judge
a friendship you and I are both like
this as going
that's what a good friend is or hardcore
I remember when we went to but sometimes
the best thing we can do for people is
remove our presents so they can have a
consequence
oh yeah oh oh yeah and then they can't
grow if we love them regardless always
my buddy Eddie Fernandez came out to L.A
he's like he's like a man he's like a
regular man like a man and and we went
to the Improv and and uh I won't say
names but uh some guy was like
uh being fresh it was a comic it was way
more successful and he was making fun of
me and like and like almost like
humiliating me and and and and he was
something way more successful than me so
I just let it happen and then Eddie goes
are we gonna smack this guy or what and
I go I was like no no no he's like a
really successful comic just let it go
and he goes fuck that he goes what
happened to you man let's beat this
guy's ass yeah and I was like Eddie just
trust me I don't want to deal with that
yeah and he was like he was like dude
what happened to you you changed he was
like you would never let a guy do that
too and I was like I was like yeah but
comedy La is different LA's different
and I know that there was a guy named uh
there was a guy oh his name is Rick I
think he was friends with Gary Goldman
well an agent said something foul to a
girl and he slapped the agent in the
face and they banned him from The Improv
and the guy quit doing comedy and he say
I think he's a social worker in
Baltimore now
he defended the girl and the agent was
more powerful and he slapped the agent
in the face or a Punchy agent whatever
he did he did he did because you know
what the girl would have had to laugh so
it's like to me I was I mean I talked
about this I uh
um yeah I don't remember who I was
talking about it the other day because
all this stuff is you know my parents
her uh mom died and I had to like be in
the Stockholm syndrome of denial and my
sister's back in my life and it's like
I'm getting a lot a lot of these
memories are coming back that I have to
impressed the things I had to repress to
keep going in comedy not complaining not
coming forward don't want anyone to Pity
Me ever but
um I remember there was a manager at the
Phoenix whatever fucking thing keep
going I know his name yep smack me on
the ass so hard yup he's dead now by the
way
um
interesting keep going and then for me
I'm like oh poor guy like that for a
second for a second that's how
conditioned I am to have compassion for
abusers because I go oh well he didn't
know her people hurt people it wasn't
his fault people hurt people yeah yeah
like whatever who gets different it's
your job to heal yourself whatever I
make excuses because otherwise you just
can't proceed yeah if I if I didn't make
excuses then I'd go what I can't work
with Sky ever again like I need to do
you know smack me on the ass sword I
have such a high tolerance for pain I
broke my shoulder snowboarding didn't go
to the doctor for four days like didn't
like couldn't put I had to start I just
accommodated it by using front clasp of
bras instead of ones you pull over
because my uh Rotator tough cuff was
torn and then went to uh get it and it
was fractured all the way through so
it's like I don't I have a high
tolerance for pain slapped me and that's
so hard
I I it burned I tears started coming
down the side and I started laughing
because you that's the only way to not
be humiliated is to have to go like high
crazy and then I remember like there was
another comment because remember I was
like now do the other side like I had to
lean into the humiliation to take it the
power back oh yeah but then you're
training people yeah then who's fault is
it the next time he slaps a girl's ass
uh I'm the one that said this is okay
I'm so funny I just had this
conversation with someone uh I'm so
proud of myself for in my past having
stood up for myself although in
hindsight but we couldn't do it till I
couldn't do it until very recently I did
it way too young of an age but I I would
I would dare to say and I and I said
this and I and I wonder how I feel about
this for real
part of me part of me
I don't wish that I'd never done it
but the headache that comes up with
standing up for yourself because once
you stand up for something it's it's why
uh it's why I respect
um
I respect like uh I don't know the right
thing to say but like uh
like let's I'm using I'm gonna use a bad
example but when let's say like uh
an underrepresented person stands up for
themselves and and says this is bullshit
this shouldn't happen she was one that
would fucking the the judge is still the
judge at Clarence Thomas yes Thomas yes
she stood up and and she subjected
herself to so much humiliation
so much picking apart so much tearing
apart her reputation uh but you are a
whore correct you are a whore uh
that I understand
I I actually understand
uh
her regret and standing up for herself
as well as her pride in standing up for
herself and here's what I'll say yeah
that's that is so beautifully put I know
you felt like you were struggling saying
that yeah
it did because the first thing I thought
was she was dragged publicly humiliated
but you know what she sleeps like a baby
which is I had to publicly come out
against uh one of my best friends about
something horrific not one person stood
behind me in the comedy community not
one especially women because they don't
want me to succeed and they would have
rather me embarrass myself and get
destroyed and be wrong then support the
thing they had all pretended they were
fighting for then me win
it I took a huge ding I it emotionally
broke me
for everyone who asks
um what happened to Whitney during the
pandemic that's what happened
I did the right thing
and um no one stood with me
I did the bravest thing uh I know that
now
and uh
it it it yeah it broke me it's the first
time I've ever felt like I want to have
uh I'm gonna have Rose at four it's
first time I've ever drank during the
day because I was in so much pain from
that
but I can sleep at night and I look back
and I know the second I had some
information I said something I behaved
with integrity and that's if we don't
have that you have nothing I don't have
to move through the world with shame or
guilt or and I see a lot of people
in our community that are kind of like
manic around me and weird with me and
I'm like yeah because you can't look me
in the eye
because
you didn't do the brave thing and you
didn't stand behind me and you know you
didn't and that's okay I didn't need
anyone to it was it was whatever it was
what it was but I think that Anita Hill
thing when you go when you go I maybe
I'm not meant to be more successful than
this maybe maybe God the universe
doesn't want me to go past a certain
point so every time I something knocks
me down and in my brain I go oh this was
such a roadblock or this was an obstacle
but maybe I'm not maybe this is good
enough maybe I don't need to be Kevin
Hart with explosions you know maybe I
just need to kind of maybe it's not
healthy for me to be any more famous or
something maybe it's unhealthy for me to
be any more successful maybe it's too
dangerous maybe it's whatever but um
because also I have such wild security
issues you know I think it's like you
know so do the guys now like we're we're
and I have questions for you about this
because it's like I as we're talking
about loving our fans like I want to
just I want to I literally every show
I'm like can I I mean my last special I
jumped into the crowd and crowd surfed
it was the most fun thing ever yeah I
want to show my fans like if like
because I'm now how you know you've
you've been you know you've inspired me
so much with how hard you've worked on
the road everything you have built has
been from you touring when people say oh
he's selling out we've made the jokes on
the roast do you sell a Smoothie King
Arena when you go into your hot tub
bullshit it's a joke it's funny but Bert
has been going back to these towns every
year for 20 years that's why they come
back and they go two people came 15
years ago and they went that was
hilarious next year I'm going to bring
do a double date to friends and then you
kill again when you come back and then
the next year they go I'm gonna bring my
office party and the next year they go
holy shit let's bring our family reunion
it your social media is brilliant and
great it does get people to know you're
there but that's not why they're buying
tickets it's because you have already
done that market so many times and the
word of mouth in that market you know so
it pisses me off when anyone says they
don't really say about you but like oh
yeah this person sells these tickets
because they're do a lot of social media
bitch that's like I've heard that about
me
I say one time but it's not right and
you'll find that you did radio in those
markets 14 years there's there's a guy
that said he'd say he's said on a
podcast I'm a real comic I'm not some
guy in a speedo just trying to sell
tickets it bother me because I had the
guy on my podcast and I was I thought we
were friends I know we're not you found
out about it after someone someone the
guy on one of the guys on the podcast
sent it to me and uh when I know people
are making um the only thing and he was
like hit me up and he was like yo he's
talking about you give you a heads up
he's not your friend and and then and
then just
it'll catch you off guard you're gonna
go really I almost kind of want to guess
because you know that the only reason I
go on Twitter anymore is When someone
tells me there's like a veiled joke
about me from a comic and then I just go
to you may not even know this I just
like to retweet it I mean I don't even
know that guy's name uh yeah I do
interesting that does I that to me
looking at the person
I think I know I did it I know I did
well there's also it's wild that
comedians at your level at our level we
want we one part of our magical thinking
is to think we deserve for people our
age that that don't have what we have to
not be jealous of us
say that again I think I missed it we
have magical thinking we want to you
want to be able to sell UH 60 000 seats
and then have a another comic your age
not be jealous of you yes how else are
they going to justify why they don't
have what you have they have to say it's
about the speedo so how about this Dane
Cook I I the guy you cannot say
someone's not funny if they're selling
20 000 tickets that's like you denying
the election results you're no you're no
worse these Capital stormers out here I
open for Dane a couple times in one time
I remember we were in Sunset Florida at
20 000 seats he came out it was so loud
I had to remove my people were holding
posters they had made it was younger
people whatever and then people saying
he's not funny he's not funny he's not
funny and I was young at the time and I
was just like well then what's your
excuse if you are I so that person was
never the person that ever thought Dane
wasn't funny I Dane made me giggle from
day one but we don't buy tickets to see
comedy who are we to weigh in yeah you
know what the funny thing is uh but I
just want to say sugar told me about
that guy but this but this guy
you and Sagar are the most successful
comedians in the world that are the same
age as this person and this person is
going if I don't think of a reason I
don't have what they have I'm gonna blow
my brains out well I won't go shirtless
into Speedo it's like when I if I say
about Alex Cooper you know she has the
biggest podcast and I'm like well I'm
not willing to talk about sex and
squirting because that's I'm just not
going to do that
it's the way that I Justified not having
the same numbers and it makes me feel
better my ego my ego needs to say that
yeah oh I I but it still hurts to hear
the inside and you watch the subtlety of
it of of the subtlety of like uh
hardcore lefties Colin Rogan uh
anti-vaxxer and and and and an alt-right
can I say something sure all lefties
right now
what are all the alt left alt right
they're on drugs they're on Edibles
they're on mushrooms they're on they're
not some of the alt right is too oh I'm
just saying do not there's no point in
even talking about these people because
the the people that come for Rogan they
it's so pathetic because they're making
him more successful oh I meant I meant
the people that listen to Rogan is
everyone everyone listens to Rogan I I
love I man I fucking love the guy I know
and I I can't believe we're going we're
going together in Austin I'm so free can
I tell you I'm nervous that uh Joe
forgot I'm doing his podcast and I
texted Joe doesn't forget a lot I feel
like uh I gotta I gotta be like can't
wait to see on Monday day buddy
right because because if you go and he
doesn't know you're gonna be there four
Navy Seals are gonna fucking be holding
arrows to your head uh he would he I
know he would be like oh fuck I fucked
up because what I did is when I knew
that the day I shot my podcast I shot my
special Netflix came to with an air date
and they were like yo we want you on
March 14th and I was like okay and then
like equal with it and I was like yeah
random as fuck uh Hey Big Boy aired on
March 17th and I loved I loved that
energy I love that that that St Patty's
Day energy I can definitely celebr
welcome it in I'm so weird with him like
I I wait for him to ask like Joe because
I was thinking oh oh yeah yeah I never
asked to be on this podcast but I texted
him when I knew my special date was
coming yeah cause I know Joe but he
posted the trailer for The Machine like
he's he's he you could ask him but it's
the kind of like he's so freaking
generous and I know if I ask he'll say
yes which is why I don't want to ask
because I never want him to think I'm
using him here's the deal here's the
deal
he's my friend right if he has to be on
my podcast I would say of course if you
said can I do your podcast uh of course
uh I have someone can I do a podcast to
promote the rose but maybe we'll just
yes
okay I want to do like a fight companion
where we're watching the roast somewhere
yeah like it's like Comics writers
comics and we can go oh here was the
joke we're gonna do Bradley Martin hit
me up to yesterday and he said hey can I
do your podcast I've never met Bradley
Morton and I don't know Bradley Martin
but I do know of him I know enough of
him right I think he's a pretty cool
dude and I and I watched enough of his
content I was like of course yeah of
course and and so as a friend I would
say I'm not going to abuse the privilege
of the biggest media company in the
world but we don't see it like that it's
weird I don't think he thinks of it like
that he does not he does not think of it
like that but when I knew the date of my
airing I first got a reached out to I go
hey buddy my podcast is coming out March
14th is there anyway I can do your
podcast he goes let's do it on the 13th
it'll air the 14th we'll blow the fuck
up out of it and I'll say of course when
the movie uh T when I wanted to leave
the movie teaser because it was sitting
on a shelf I said to Joe man hey I got
my teaser I'd love to show it to you on
the podcast and he was like let's do it
he liked it if he didn't like it he
would have said it he liked it when when
they gave me semi-control of of getting
the announce video and and with and with
all the things Joe's been so generous to
me but as a friend I understand you have
to understand how he looks at his
friends his friends yeah just friends
yeah and then also like
I I'm hyper aware of how many people are
blowing him up on a daily basis like I
know what my phone looks like and I'm
not Joe Rogan but he changes his number
so often he's he's actually like he has
boundaries for days like like Bert you
and I both I'm not saying we have to
work on this but we're very similar and
that we you know we let people have so
much access to us because we don't see
ourselves as like you know and we allow
ourselves to be used and we and we allow
ourselves to be ATM machines but I don't
mean that always money energy ATM
machines like oh I'm definitely an
energy I do the same thing I have people
that book shows and bring your shows and
if and and people that need things I
actually give them more access to me
weirdly than the people that don't
because I'm like oh it's my job to help
people it's my job to you know what if I
change my number and this person can't
text me and they feel rejected even
though they do nothing but use me and
see me as uh you know a show Pony to
make money off of whatever because I
know how desperate I was and like if a
comedian that had power said I can help
you and meant it I'd be like can I have
this can I have this can you do this can
you do this show because I've trained
them to use me I've trained them so I I
can't change my phone number why not Joe
does it every six months Sebastian does
it every six months and I have the same
phone number I've had for literally 20
years well I have the same phone my old
one the 323 number that everyone has
I uh look at my look at my um hold on
this is this is look at my text messages
just read that out loud that number
top left oh wow let me see what does it
say 1700. I have 1700 text messages
because when I see someone that won't
stop asking favors I go this person's in
trouble I need to help them right and
then you help but give an inch take a
mile huh that person is in trouble no
like deep trouble and I think also
because Comics we've seen so many people
die yeah and you go well if I don't
respond to this and this person's
hanging from a doorknob in their house
tomorrow
you know what I mean I agree there were
times that you know there's like because
this feels like we're due we're due from
a com for a comedian hanging from a
doorknob and that's where my brain goes
because it's like Geraldo like didn't
text him back he was just because I was
on the road you know and the death rate
is pretty high in our business right oh
Jeffrey's pretty high I just want to
live forever hold on I want to show you
I sent all the jokes about Joe that were
in the roast I sent to him like saying
are these okay yeah and he was dying
because I was like Rogan is gonna make
like I kind of thought like Rogan
doesn't like rose like everyone loves
roast the way we're doing it yeah you
know what I mean but there was a bunch
of like Rogan jokes and do you remember
let me just ask you a question really
quick before I let you go do you
remember much of the Rose no I don't
remember any of it okay I did not know
that I spoke at the end
when you said oh here's your part I went
I spoke or when we watched it and you
went yeah and I said oh my God and I
started panicking and I was like please
tell me what you said what I said and
you know I think you'll like it I want
and I wanna I'm not gonna share what I
said because I think it's it's worth you
watching the roads to see it but I was
like thank fucking god Kesha had been
waiting for two hours
she looked great amazing
you were so fucking pretty
man there's uh there's something about
Kesha that I go her energy her little
bit of a rock starness like everything
about her she looked absolutely
beautiful man I am and she's way younger
than me way younger than me but I think
I'm cool in saying that is like as a fan
she looks fucking awesome but she's just
but she's like an angel she's like you
you see her and you're like oh I'll join
this cult
like I'll tell you I'll tell you this is
a tablet inappropriate but I will say
that in a in a parallel universe in a
parallel universe
cash is the chick that you wake up with
in the morning and she and you you go
where is she and then she comes in with
Otter Pops because you want an Otter Pop
and you're like I'm in an opera pop him
forever and she goes we got pretty
wasted last night we need to hydrate and
you're like really and he says you go
what is a little salty and she goes they
are uh they're Pedialyte Otter Pops I
thought we needed this and you're like
God damn it I fucking love Kesha she's
the girl she is the great were you
surprised my concerned well I know I
know I know everyone's concerned but how
about this bird I go backstage Kesha's
standing waiting Josh Potter's in a
wedding dress yeah for a skit that was
get done and I rehearsed for two and a
half hours yeah fell totally apart uh
and then one of my writers was in a
Kool-Aid costume and a and do you
remember the Kool-Aid guy coming I don't
remember that so I don't remember that I
remember randomly seeing you ready for
this randomly this is watching thing
something I'd worked on for a month just
fall apart in real time
I randomly run into Miranda Cosgrove
she was coming out at the end to do
another bit that we didn't get to but
yeah well I see her on stage and I go
hey
I know you and she was like hi and I was
like wait you're the I say fuck oh shit
that's B yeah and I was like good
because you told I didn't know who she
was until you told me about her and then
I didn't know that clip was her and then
I was like the viral I was like oh my
God I know you the viral clip of because
and I have cake on my face I'm shirtless
I have a a belt lump in my stomach
because I've been sitting on a fucking
cowboy belt which Jay oakerson
because he also just went I'm gonna make
fun of the factless I got to write jokes
and then he said he said bro I know what
it's like to have that belt buckle
digging into your stomach right now but
also my biggest fear was when Kasha came
out you'd be too drunk and wouldn't
recognize her well I recognize her
immediately it didn't hurt that you were
playing Gadget music
because I I wanted to give Bert this
like surprise moment well I knew that
you knew I liked Kesha loved we've
facetimed her on your podcast before yes
I can get emotional talking about Kesha
and I knew that you knew that so when
the music played I was like oh cool so
no homage I never in a million years
thought I'd meet Kesha
she loves you she I fucking adore that
woman not only does she love you she
waited for two hours yeah backstage at
The Comedy Store I have Kesha backstage
at the Green
Comedy Store I no I'm not with her I'm
like oh God what's going on back there
like I'm that's remember I was like
running around all manic
yeah I was that was such an event I
don't remember any of it I do remember I
remember this is the last thing I really
remember is because well I'll try to get
her at your Premiere too yeah because
we're doing the premiere and I'm gonna
just really quick this is like literally
this is the invite list because we're
doing an influencer Premiere we're a new
content creation like upfronts remember
upfronts for TV shows your Premiere your
brain is going to be content creation
there's and then we're doing a screening
you heard me talk about this like this
this is the way I talk this is the way I
talk I love what you're saying I love
when you take the old format and you
turn it into what was the new upfronts
you have to you have to just but that's
in words you know that we understand
this is a press event we've got uh uh
we're doing photo booths video booths
content creation we've got the 3D
machine so people can post everyone's
posting and I'm trying to go everywhere
it's like Howie Mandel Melissa Rivers
Tori Spelling Dita vontes Kevin Nealon
Rachel Bilson Kat Von D Jason Bateman Mo
Amber Natasha Leggero Paris Hilton uh
all the Liquidators
you know what I mean and then I want to
just show this clash between like it's
not about repo like Republican Democrat
it's about reasonable people it's not
about
comedians versus Hollywood it's about
the coolest people in Hollywood and the
coolest comedians you know like because
we've been so bifurcated for so long
because it goes from like yeah Paris
Hilton uh Jeanette McCurdy on iCarly
also Jared Fogle exactly uh uh
[Music]
another thing I want to do with the rest
moving forward is uniting drag and at my
roast Bob the drag queen was on it
Comedians and drag are the same same can
I tell you I wanna I wanna I wanna do an
I I I'm I have this idea about you know
what's really cool is I never heard I
knew Lisa Lampanelli literally this list
goes Chrissy Teigen Andrew Santino John
Legend Bobby Lee this is gonna be a very
weird event the premiere we have it in
this calendar right John Legend has the
most engaging smile he's the best I was
on a flight with him he was going to
Chappelle's uh Chappelle's doing uh I
think maybe he was doing a special or he
was doing the Mark Twain Awards or
something yeah and John Legend was going
and he was on my flight and I don't I'm
not I know I'm not obviously I'm not a
huge John Legend fan I don't I know I
know who he is you just don't I don't
know I'm not going to recognize him off
like be like oh shit John Legend but he
walked back from the bathroom we're
sitting in first class I was in the
front row and he walked just past me and
he smiled and I went that guy's got it
in in my heart like the way he smiles
just big fucking sweet smile he's the
greatest I'm working on some with him
I'm doing this uh we're doing a show
together about like going back to your
hometown and like being from West
Virginia and like going back it's called
take me home and like you can like help
him get clean water to West Virginia
it's me Jose Andres and him and we're
rebuilding a hotel in West Virginia he's
the greatest also my best friend from
college runs his company
separately but he's just the greatest
but it's like it used to be Friars Club
Roast like oh I want to say remember
Sinatra in Rodney Dangerfield were best
friends
yeah I mean we're forgetting like
because we're kind of going oh screw
musicians what we do is harder musicians
are going we kind of want to be comics
and Comics like we kind of want to be
rock stars and there's like it used to
be more united can I put a thought
bubble out there yes and this is a dirty
thought bubble
but like
how crazy is it that without the death
of Kurt Cobain who is probably the
greatest artist of Our Generation we
wouldn't get the
the great art of Dave Grohl
isn't that a weird thought that if Kurt
Cobain had lived maybe maybe Dave would
have stayed a drummer for Nirvana the
greatest rock band of Our Generation and
we would have never gotten the maybe
have you been to Urban Outfitters
recently with your daughters no if you
go to Urban Outfitters all the clothes
for teenagers are like Nirvana shirts
and I'm kind of like do they even know
what this is it's kind of like a wild
thing yeah I mean I was such a Nirvana
fan I can't tell you it's I don't think
I and I'm gonna say something else which
is like would we have gotten does Dave
does do you think Dave Grohl thinks we
would have gotten our Dave Grohl because
we got Dave Grohl and and by the way I
mean perfectly timed out artistically
perfectly also I did the Dave I did the
um Foo Fighters horror movie also a
hilarious actor Dave Grohl is hilarious
a hilarious person it's crazy to think
but also it's not the time to ask him
because he also just lost his drummer
from food I mean it's like the deaths
it's like you know I think we need to
start
um attuning more with musicians because
they lose their friends the way we do
they lose their co-workers the way we do
drug overdoses suicides I wonder what
the the Courtney Love I mean you know if
we had not lost Patrice we'd still have
Anthony
from Opie and Anthony okay that took me
a second I mean like if Patrice is still
alive when all that shit went down
Patrice would have just stood up for
Anthony I still haven't processed
Geraldo passing like they're Brody like
I don't think I went to the room he died
in I just pretend they're on the road I
don't I don't process that they've died
I went to the room he died in like I
went to the like I was drunk and I was
at the stress Factory
the room Geraldo died in yeah and they
told me what room and I was like
what if he tripped and fell and died I
will have thought part of me thought
part of me thought so so full disclosure
full disclosure I'm drunk right I'm
drunk It's the first time I sell out a
weekend that's my first time ever I'm
feeling my oats at the stress Factory
they call it that because that's how you
feel when you're in the green room it's
the Green Room wasn't isn't perfect it's
six six years ago
and um sold out and it's Sunday night
and it's a blizzard
and I and and someone tells me you know
Geraldo died across the street at the
hotel you're in I said wait what room
and they tell me the room and I went oh
wow so I go down and I said hey is uh
dot dot dot room sold out
and they said uh no
I said can I get a key to that room
I would like to I would like to go into
that room to have a moment and they're
like absolutely hey guys I'm in Tampa
this weekend this is where Greg draw
today
and so I go and they said absolutely not
I said can I rent that room out
so that I can go into that room so I
thought I thought would be a cool way to
say goodbye to a friend you know to go
to the place you passed and they said uh
and by the way I didn't have money at
the time so it was not cost effective
but I thought I'd grab a beer and I went
out and stood outside the room and I
just stood outside the room and murdered
a beer and I thought
thought man fuck I wish I could have I
wish I wish we could have stopped you
from the shit that went down they oddly
enough they walked me through the whole
evening of the night he passed and how
fucked up it was and it was tremendously
fucked up from what I heard
um same night I watched a waitress choke
out a waiter it's fun the funny hardest
I've ever laughed in my life it's the
hardest I've ever left we're sitting
there and uh Mickey Galls with us he's a
cage fighter he's an MMA UFC guy and
some girl goes so you really can choke
out a guy and he goes yeah he's like
show me how to choke out someone he goes
well it's really easy you put this arm
under their chin and then put your hand
here and then put it behind their head
and just squeeze and she goes ah oh wow
that works and he goes yeah and he goes
should do it and so she gets the
bartender and she puts her hand under
like this and he goes yeah yeah and then
I put my hand like this and he goes now
squeeze and she squeezes and the
bartender Taps her arm but no one ever
taught what a tap was and he goes
unconscious and drops to the ground and
cracks his head just oh she goes so that
fucking works they're so fucking crazy
and the guy's unconscious on the ground
Mickey calls slipping him over on his
back grabbing his legs shaking his legs
like yeah you choke this fucking dude
out I laughed so hard the moment she
tapped and we realized collectively oh
we never taught her what the tap meant
the Taps just stopped choking fuck
no
that is uh I need to start doing that
with men in bed can I start tapping them
to stop choking me
I never understood ref sucks I said this
earlier I know I have a list of things
that we didn't get to finish just so you
guys don't think let's do another
podcast we'll do another one I just want
to let you know the birth control being
a racket all this I tag oh really quick
can I just pitch you the tagline for
only fans comedy because they're gonna
have a big billboard outside of the show
yeah and they're doing only fans comedy
like they're breaking out an arm where
it's like no censorship like comedians
because where do you go if you're a
comedian who's a feature right now to
get a half hour an hour there's no way
to do it you're gonna die on YouTube
taglines for only fans comedy only fans
comedy what about this come come hard
laugh hard
or just come laugh hard
I like I like that no come hard I like
come like we get to come up let's try to
I have to come up with like basically
the tagline for a network
I like calm Calm Laugh hard come for the
laughs
I'm gonna pitch that for the laughs
laugh stay for the come show us your
jokes
yeah I like show you jokes we keep them
coming
jokes yeah yeah I like jokes
my jokes are up here
God you're going way faster than me
that's why I never was in The Writer's
room with you uh how about how about
like porn like porn but degrading
like porn only degrading yeah yeah yeah
comedy the only fans comedy because my
thing is it's comedy fans only only come
here if you're a comedy fan if you don't
if you wanna if you wanna Jesus Christ
you're moving way too fast for me like
uh yeah yeah yeah I like only fans only
comedy fans because it's like like
that's that's already sort of the thing
because it's like if you're not a common
oh and yeah yeah yeah oh and you can do
that you can do that only with comedy in
between underneath like kind of ghost
written and then fans only fans because
people if you're not a comedy fan and
you're intentionally gonna misunderstand
this joke in order to justify being
offended don't come here this
fans only we're gonna do a not safe
comedy for the comedy how about how
about how about if you get offended will
leak who you're uh subscribed to
[Music]
I'm obsessed with the idea that that uh
that the next the next Sony League the
next metoo thing is where they release
the shit we've Googled on on YouTube on
red YouTube Red YouTube we'll release
your um yeah your Google search be
careful with what you release
um uh
or what about
this is Madison Sinclair's pitch
brilliant comedian writer she was a
writer on the roast she's fucking
hilarious
she's so funny her bitch more fatherless
Behavior
that's really great I just checked your
text for her bitches that's great oh
shit that is so fucking dumb the one
place comedians don't get fucked
I need to get on only fans more I have a
pitch with them next week only fans yeah
really
I mean I'm basically putting row Strokes
that I do like corporate gigs and when I
Tour on there instead of dirty photos
and dirty videos and sturdy jokes that I
can't tell anywhere else people love it
I think that's gonna be the main
platform for people to do comedy I think
the log line should be watch us come on
his tits for mine
oh
the the worst set of tits on only pets
you're like I love this because I think
everyone's saying bird Chrysler is the
best Storyteller on the planet you're
also a fucking incredible joke writer
I'm not the best Joker I know but it's
better I'm much better at a story
because I think that's a brilliant joke
the worst set of tits on Lily fans like
that could be the thing yeah
or the best or the best or the best or
are tits we don't feel comfortable
charging you to see
free subscription for these tits
um I love you I'm Gonna Let You Go
there's so many things I wanted to get
to but this is what we do I I absolutely
adore you Whitney so does my family the
girls love you Leanne loves you I am so
happier in my life the greatest and um
I I just love you so much and I won't
stop saying it don't ride elephants you
guys it's Bert Kreischer um his I mean
you're gonna you've already seen the
special and you're gonna watch it again
and again and again and again right I
look great now dude not only do you look
great it's a brilliant your titles are
always the best your bill posters are
always the best your Crowds Are the best
your shit's the best you're just the
best
I love to end on that I love you guys
goodbye
[Music]